Mr Foster what is your true full name
please
for the first time we are now hearing
directly from that kidnapping suspect
before he was found dead in Oregon
Benjamin Foster died by suicide in
Oregon but not before he tortured a
woman and killed two men as our eight
news now investigators reported earlier
this week Foster was convicted on
similar charges right here in Las Vegas
we've been covering this story with
eight news now investigator David
Charles now here live in studio with the
video that David has uncovered well
Brian it certainly is Eerie to hear the
voice of a man who police say tortured a
woman he met on a dating app and then
killed two men now before that he was
living and working here where he held a
woman captive for weeks Mr Foster what
is your true full name please
Benjamin Foster appears here in this Las
Vegas courtroom in 2019 on kidnapping
charges do you understand the charges
issue I believe so yes Foster had held a
woman captive for two weeks shaving her
head and beating her he tied her up with
zip ties and duct tape telling her
cameras were watching documents they've
used how investigators obtained
revealing the woman told police Foster
blacked out the windows and made her
take sleeping pills is that your
understanding of the deal
yes sir the woman was able to escape
when she convinced Foster to allow them
to go to a grocery store Foster took a
plea deal in this court hearing from
September 2021 the Alfred plea meant
Foster did not admit guilt but agreed
prosecutors had enough evidence to
convict him is there anything you want
to say I'm going to give you the
sentence that you guys agreed to
having served nearly two years in jail
the Nevada Department of Corrections
released Foster the same day he arrived
at the agency's intake facility and we
won't rest until we capture this man The
Manhunt for Foster's arrest in Oregon
lasting several days police later
finding him hiding under a house
now the kidnapping Survivor here telling
police Fosters mental health declined
after he was fired from his job police
in Oregon telling the Associated Press
it was quote extremely troubling Foster
was released for credit for time served
but that was the stipulation of that
plea deal I'm David charns 8 news now
David thank you now police in Oregon say
Fosters kidnapping victim there is
stable at last check she was in the
hospital in a coma